real quick uh I want to mention that
there was a bizarre and horrifying event
in Philadelphia that kind of went wacky
um white supremacists participated in a
rally a March in Philadelphia
uh meant to be about supposed election
Integrity by which they mean that Trump
really won check out this report from
HuffPost a white supremacist group based
in Texas attempted a march on
Philadelphia over the Independence Day
weekend but had to celebrate the holiday
the Confederate way they literally ran
away from the people of Philadelphia
Michael Crum a police officer in the
city told the local ABC station WPVI
about 200 masked and khaki-clad members
of the Patriot front organization listed
as a white nationalist hate Group by the
Southern Poverty Law Center marched on
the city in the Saturday night incident
NBC Philadelphia reported they chanted
about the election and reclaimed America
engaged in pushing and shoving with
people and took a reporter cell phone
but that boldness quickly faded as more
residents turned out
they started engaging with citizens of
Philadelphia who were none too happy
about what they were saying these males
felt threatened and at one point
somebody in their crowd threw a type of
smoke bomb to cover their Retreat
they're treating this like a tactical
event they covered their Retreat Philly
mayor Jim Kenney said he was appalled
that the group chose his City for its
demonstration
saying while we respect everyone's right
to exercise Free Speech our
Administration stands against everything
these groups represent racism
intolerance and hate have no place here
there are videos of white supremacist
groups using what look to be toy Shields
to protect themselves
it's all just absolutely and completely
bizarre one member of the white
supremacist group was hit and fell when
another member pulled the truck's
roll-up door down slamming him in the
head in the process I'm not going to
play the clip but it is there there were
no arrests nor were there reports of
injuries or damage so of course I'm not
for violence of any kind I'm not for
violence by the protesters and assuming
that it is not in self-defense I'm also
not for violence against these people a
couple interesting notes Here number one
it's great that this went a different
way than Charlottesville Virginia early
in Donald Trump's presidency of course
you never want to see that number two
it's not lost on me that the people that
are Clinging On to the Trump really one
narrative include all sorts of uh of
radicals including in this case white
nationalists and it's good that the
government is paying attention to the to
the fact that that's a reality and then
number three again uh does it matter
whether the white nationalists really
think Trump won or whether they are just
using it as an excuse to get out there
and cause chaos it doesn't really matter
much the same way that there's people
who say Trump's anti-semitic and then
the counter is Trump's not anti-semitic
his son-in-law is Jewish his daughter
converted to Judaism his grandkids are
Jewish oh but you could still have
Jewish family and it doesn't matter if
he emboldens and coalesces the
anti-semitic people and the white
nationalists what is deep in Trump's
mind doesn't actually really matter the
actions are what matter here and the
actions in this particular case are that
all sorts of radicals are getting
involved in this I I hate I feel stupid
even calling it election Integrity
movement it's really a wreak havoc and
try to steal the election movement uh
all of those groups are getting involved
and we'll see what impact they have uh
on the 2022 election quite frankly